I mean sometimes they don't want to hear
it like I have female friends that will
ask me stuff
um about the way guys are acting and you
tell them and they they're still okay
with what's happening because they'll
still like
go along with the game that he's playing
Because deep you probably know it's a
game but you're enjoying it and you want
I think I think they just see
um I think they just see potential they
go the game's happening hopefully he's
gonna change
um I want him to change and
he'll change for me because he's with me
he's here and this is what I want so
it's the delusion in them selfish in
some regards but it is what it is